[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
fraude évasion fiscale le Sénat fait les
comptes
comment les pouvoirs publics peuvent-ils
intensifier la lutte contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale la mission
d'information de la commission des
finances relatives à la lutte contre la
fraude et l'évasion fiscale présidée par
Claude Raynal et dont Jean-François
Husson était le rapporteur a rendu ses
conclusions en réalisant un bilan de la
mise en oeuvre des dispositions adoptées
dans le cadre de la loi relative à la
lutte contre la fraude du 23 octobre
2018 les sénateurs ont constaté que les
résultats du contrôle fiscal avaient
enregistré une amélioration depuis 2018
avec une hausse de 38% des résultats
néanmoins le rapport fait état d'un
défaut d'évaluation de la fraude
préjudiciable à l'appréciation des
résultats du contrôle fiscal
la mission déplore un manque de
magistrats et d'enquêteurs spécialisés
en matière économique et financière
alors que les dossiers de fraude fiscale
transmis au parquet sont en hausse de
75% depuis 2018
d'où la nécessité de soutenir le service
d'enquête judiciaire des Finances à cet
égard la mission préconise de doubler
par redéploiement le nombre d'officiers
fiscaux judiciaires d'ici 5 ans elle
recommande aussi de clarifier les
modalités de levée du secret
professionnel au profit des assistances
spécialisées chargés d'aider les
procureurs
par ailleurs la mission relève que la
fraude à la TVA a représenté entre 20 et
25 milliards d'euros de pertes de
recettes fiscales en 2021 selon l'INSEE
pour combler cette faille la mission
propose notamment de renforcer la
coopération entre la direction générale
des finances publiques et la douane dans
le contrôle à la fraude à la TVA les
rapporteurs constatent que l'accès aux
données en ligne est essentielle pour
repérer l'effet de fraude fiscale il est
toutefois nécessaire de renforcer les
garanties juridiques des dispositifs
d'accès aux données en ligne pour les
rendre plus opérationnelles
concernant l'évasion fiscale à l'échelle
planétaire les capitaux détenus dans des
paradis fiscaux représenterait 8% du
produit intérieur brut mondial
résultat une perte de recettes fiscale
de l'ordre de 155 milliards d'euros par
an pour déjouer les montages financiers
abusifs la mission formule des
recommandations visant à accroître les
échanges d'information entre les États à
renforcer la transparence des
informations relatives au bénéficiaires
effectifs de société offshore et à
engager une révision des conventions
fiscales
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]